I hate intro psych go past season two
we're gonna kick things off with an
explosion going off in a public square
and although there weren't any
casualties the Public Safety Bureau are
sent to handle it
fuckin'-a is back at it and working with
a new inspector Micah's she mutsuki and
some new enforcers sakuya Tokido and
Shou Hina Kawa do Nosa and Yayoi from
season 1 are still working with her as
well after he knows his demotion to
enforcer they pinpoint the perps hideout
and close in on him but it turns out to
be a trap with a bomb detonating when
they get close the suspect manages to
escape in the chaos and takes a hostage
with him it releases the hostage soon
after but they figure it's a decoy or
another trap so they stick on the
suspect
once they corner him aki-nee sees that
his psychopath score is just over 300
warranting lethal action from her
Dominator she decides against killing
him and instead tries to calm him down
enough to lower his score this ends up
working and she is able to use the
dominators paralysis mode instead of
killing him meanwhile an inspector from
division to mizu Ishii Suey and her
enforcer Yama TOA tracked down the
hostage the woman turns out to be a man
who doesn't register on the dominator
scans he injects mazui with a drug
paralyzing her and uses her Dominator to
kill yama toya the killer also leaves
behind a message reading WC written in
blood Yepez o - fuckin'-a interrogate
the bomber to find out how he was able
to keep his hue so clear while preparing
the bombs and avoiding detection he
hysterically explains that somebody else
was helping him and is responsible for
keeping his score low inspector a Yanagi
is helping with the case but doesn't buy
his story because nobody else was
detected in the area they learned the
fake hostage was a complicated hologram
model based off of a young girl that
died years ago soon after the Bombers
core mysteriously drops drastically
beneath that of a latent criminal
resulting in him being transferred to a
different facility back at her apartment
aki-nee notices WC scratched into her
wall
right before she is informed that the
bomber attacked a Yanagi and escaped
good catch up to him after a short chase
and he is killed by a you Nagi as he
utters the name Kamui
they also learned that the WC might
stand for what color referring to the
hue of a person as in what kind of
person are you
episode 3 inspectors she sewer that was
drugged and captured by the mastermind
Kyoto cop Mori wakes up tied to a chair
missing an eye her score starts to race
sporadically as she realizes the
situation but then Camus he does
something that makes her score suddenly
drop and calms her down back to Aachen
and the others who were investigating
the message that appeared in her
apartment but don't find anything she
goes to get help from Saiga who's locked
up after turning himself in for helping
kogami in season 1 after that she meets
with chief Cass a to get permission to
dive deeper into the case chasing this
ghost casei approves of this but also
warns Aachen aid to be wary of one of
her and horses toga named Rock you made
partner goes out on a call to arrest a
public figure named Masuda who says to
call Kamui because he'll make him better
again meanwhile a Yanagi had went to a
mental care facility after being told to
by the captured cyclops she soui over
the phone a crazy man suddenly takes all
of the people in the facility hostage
including a Yanagi who can't use her
Dominator because his score isn't high
at all he also mentioned something about
Kamui keeping his hue clear the episode
for the prisoners inside are stripped
down by the man who then starts beating
them to death one by one to raise their
scores the whole time he claims to be
doing this in the name of Kamui his
Savior bhakta May gets a hunch that
Camus is actually somewhere inside the
facility and is able to use dominators
planning that she can't use her
Dominator ienaga rushes the culprit
stabbing him with some glass shoe then
releases the security doors to get help
from division 1 which is a kinase
division and division 3 agents outside
however since everybody score is way too
high from the stressful situation they
are slaughtered by the agents in
Division 3 this includes aya Nagi who
was shot by a sniper because she had one
of the highest scores
what alchemy arrives on the scene they
find another WC on the ground inside the
facility episode 5 she sue Eid now seems
to be under Kamui spell and he's using
her eye to wield a Dominator well
investigating the massacre seen mica
spots token a pointing his Dominator at
Aachen aid supposably check her score
the next day Division one and three are
sent out to an
Festa gay a drone warehouse well doing
so aki-nee and togi may come across the
holographic wall covering a secret room
inside the room our masks made up of
people's faces and another WC written on
the wall the combat drones that are
being built at the facility suddenly
start to come online the drones are
being piloted by people on their phones
who think they're playing a new game
called hungry chicken when in reality
they're using the drones to kill people
Saiga who is helping with the
investigation talks with the public
figure Masuda after studying his
speeches he noticed that he's actually
an entirely different person over - Myka
who is now suspicious of tokin a after
what she saw so she goes to investigate
his room she finds an alarming amount of
photos and files on aki-nee II episode 6
Sharona is working on preventing the
game from spreading to more devices och
you may soon realizes that Kamui's real
goal is to collect the dominators so she
orders enforcers to stay near their
inspectors since the dominators won't
work on them
she Suey is there with Kamui and kills
one of the lone enforcers to retrieve
his Dominator after destroying most of
the combat drones the hungry chicken
gauge starts using police drones instead
Jun is able to stop the program from
making it look like a game and shows the
players what they're actually doing this
leads to a lot of people scores
skyrocketing from seeing the carnage
that they caused akame manages to find
Kamui but can't take action because he's
still invisible to the Dominator they
have a brief and rather pointless talk
before he escapes on a boat with she
Suey episode 7 Mika and her enforcers go
around trying to stop people who were
still playing the game despite knowing
that they're killing other people
meanwhile akame is trying to find out
what Kamui is planning on doing with the
dominators we have a brief scene of
akane checking up on her grandmother who
was hospitalized and after that she goes
to see chief cos a cos a is okay with
killing Kamui suggesting that the Sibyl
system can't integrate him in like the
typical asymptomatic criminal Sakuya
picked up on the fact that miko was
snooping around his room because he has
a camera recording while he's gone mika
did some more digging on him and found
out that all of the inspectors he
previously worked under became layton
criminals and were executed by him
mikawa who discovered another hollow
similar to the hostage hollow in episode
1 both hollows were aged versions of
kids that died in a plane crash 15 years
ago they find out the crash had one
survivor
Kamui giving them his full name they
follow this up by taking in yo hey ma
Tsuzuki a surgeon that was working with
Kamui after aging up the other children
from the crash they learned that Kamui
has dozens of people working with him
right under their noses
he episode 8 during his interrogation MA
Sasaki explains to Saiga why Kamui is
invisible to the Sibyl system after
surviving the crash he was integrated
with parts from a hundred and eighty
four other bodies and multiple surgeries
including seven brain parts the system
can't measure a collective group of
people like that so he became invisible
he hated feeling invisible so his goal
is to be measured asking what color am I
and what color is a Sibyl system Mika
found out that the one responsible for
Kamui surgeries is sakis mother Masako
toga nae who died five years ago
they think that Kimura might be seeking
revenge on the token a foundation for
making him invisible
Mika tried to pass this information
along to chief casei this kind of
backfires because Masako tuggin 8 was
actually integrated into the Sibyl
system her son sakuya restrains mika and
they plan to test how she responds to
learning the truth about the Sibyl
system
episode 9 miko learns about the people
who make up the Sibyl system as well as
the fact that sakuya is actually an
artificially created human they then
want to use Micah's help to turn on ice
you black but first they have to kill
Misaki who knew too much about Mexico
after working with her during Kamui
surgeries once he's gone they set their
sights on achenes grandmother away who's
still in the hospital
meanwhile a kanay follows up on a lead
in the form of Koichi Kawashima who was
a childhood friend of Kamui couch she
helps Kamui get revenge on a company
that benefited from turning a blind eye
to the plane crash akame and the others
arrive on the scene shortly after where
Kamui had fled but co-ed she stays
behind to greet them he then gives a box
to akut containing the ear of her
grandmother alloy causing her to go into
a rage
Komori makes his next move hijacking a
subway train and we get a short look at
achenes grandmother who's actually being
held captive by sakuya episode 10 Kimora
uses explosives to flood the subways
taking 500 passengers hostage he then
uses the dominators to paralyze the
passengers and with too many people
being paralyzed it causes an overload in
the system giving them access to its
bypass system kaze shows pictures of
okones now dead grandmother - were to
try and convince her to assassinate
Kamui she decides against this of course
and goes into the subway tunnels where
she runs into sakuya she tells him that
she had to do the connection between him
and his mother in the Sibyl system along
with their plans to cloud her hue by
killing Kamui Kimura then appears behind
them and prepares to fire his Dominator
at sakuya ii episode 11 a kanay blocks
Kamui shot preventing the Dominator from
going up and she subdue sakuya she
handcuffed sakuya and leaves him behind
to take Kamui to the sibyl's core before
they could reach the core they are
confronted by casei being piloted by
Mitsuko simple had gained the ability to
measure her score as an individual even
though she's in the Sibyl system her
score ends up being over 300 so Kamui
goes on to execute her cyborg body after
dealing with her they continue on to the
core of Sybil once there Sybil for the
first time acknowledges Kamui's
existence by authorizing the measurement
of a collective psychopath with this new
skill it can also measure itself as a
collective psychopath when Sybil
measures itself the score is too high so
it begins destroying some of the
high-scoring brains lowering its overall
score down to zero where you get a quick
look at she Suey who was still holding
off the other agents and has eventually
paralyzed neutralizing the threat back
over to aki-nee who was ordered by Sybil
to kill Kamui which accused the entrance
of sakuya he's still dedicated to trying
to darken achenes hue so he begins to
brag about how he was actually the one
that killed her grandmother
Kamui calms her down before anything can
happen and he stands up to sakuya both
of them end up trading dominators shots
and Kamui is killed instantly
[Music]
sakuya survives a shot and screws away
where he is later found by mika she
considers executing him for forcing her
to be a pawn in his plan but can't bring
herself to do it it doesn't matter
though because he later bleeds out and
mika keeps everything about her forced
cooperation as well as Sybil's true form
to herself i'm going to be doing the
future seasons and that'll be in the
bottom left whenever I'm finished with
the or you can check out all the
Psychopaths recaps in this playlist here
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing I
hate more than intros is outros